uh
i wanted to first of all explore
building apps for mobile i i've never
done it
so that was one thing i wanted to do and
i had already been
you know doing stuff with closure for a
while and i was curious actually just
how much of an app can you write with
closure
or actually close your script and i
started exploring that
and so there is uh so if you're writing
for android
there's somebody writing a clojure wrap
right i think over the
android sdk and i may have heard of
someone writing a
a closure compiler for objective c
and so there are there are options so
the way that i went about it is that
i set it up with a cordova and clojure
script and i'm going to talk about
how that all works if you're not
familiar with that
so if you've got just your basic mobile
app
you've got your native app and you use
the sdk to write it right
and one of the ui elements
that's offered you know by all these uh
by android ios
is a browser widget right and this
browser widget is a ui element
you package your web resources into it
and then you can present it to the user
and so you can build your user interface
in this user in this widget and you can
execute javascript in this widget and so
that's
that is on ios on the iphone it is a
kind of like having mobile safari but
without jet
uh in yes with ios 8 that's not true
anymore
right right right i saw i saw that
yeah thank you i saw david nolan post
that it's a window
okay cool so uh it's a thing that lets
you load web pages as far as i'm
concerned so uh
you could also potentially load a remote
website and
theoretically you could maybe even
update that portion of your app if
apple approves your app with that
functionality
and i don't know if you can trust the
internet but somebody wrote that
they got an app like that approved but
you know that's probably not
something you can consistently expect to
be able to do
so where quarterback comes in it's
basically a bridge
it's up it's an apache open source
project you
may have also heard of phonegap they are
analogous they're like
chrome and chromium i think that's the
relationship
and and so it's like a bridge between
the javascript
that's running in your ui webview that
would be the ios version of a
web window and
and that is the bridge and it provides a
uniform javascript api
and then it provides implementations for
the respective platforms
so you have an objective-c
implementation you know
android implementation in java etc
and so and you have a mechanism by which
you can actually
call a native code from your javascript
and vice versa and you can get you know
return value
i don't know that exact mechanism i
believe it has something to do with the
url string in the ui webview
and the reason i don't know about it is
because cordoba takes care of all of
that
and they provide basically apis that do
all of these things so if you need to do
any of this stuff
there's an api and you can call it from
javascript
you can pass a callback and you can get
a return value in your
javascript callback from in this case
would be
objective c or whatever the native thing
is
and so the way cordover then bundles
your app
uh it just it takes your resources and
it'll then
build the respective native apps
right so it'll wrap them in the
respective
ui webviews and these other platforms
that are supported
i didn't really do anything except ios
so i'm not sure if it's really
very feasible to use it to sort of write
code once and run it on
all those platforms but because there
are a lot of sort of stumbling blocks
with that
so i don't think that's really something
you can expect but
there's a portion of your code that
could potentially be uh
reusable so the limitations are that
it's basically the
most common denominator the api that
comes with cordova is just the lowest
common
denominator of the functionality that is
provided by the various
platforms so it'd probably be
insufficient if you were doing something
you know
that was slightly more sophisticated so
just for example the problem that i ran
into with my project was that uh
the media api from cordova lets you
play back and record audio but you
cannot access the
music on your iphone that is part of
your ipod music
so uh another problem for example that i
had so the
av audio recorder class there
it can provide it has these methods for
recording for a specified amount of time
or
starting recording at a specific point
in time
and all you get with quarter way is just
a generic record
so if you need you know sort of again if
you get outside those boundaries you
need to
do custom plugins and luckily
quarterback provides a way to do that
and it's very straightforward so
that same asynchronous messaging system
that they use to implement their
plugins those apis uh you basically have
access to it
and all you've got to do is write uh
the javascript a and some native code
portions of your plug and then you have
your own plugin
is it synchronous yeah the threading i
mean four years ago i worked for a
company that where we built almost
exactly the same thing as cordova but
for
in-app advertising so you can have like
the actual advertising in
the javascript a web ui view layer and
then you would take
a native sdk and embed that into your
application
and the way that the synchronization
works is it's really wacky because
ios and android allow you to inject
javascript into like the ui uh
webview window it doesn't necessarily
give you the actual like
cigarettes result back so you actually
have to get these funky
callback loops where it's like you you
inject
you guys the native side objective c
called
the execute something in the javascript
interpreter in the window
it then calls back into the
objective c side of things to give you a
determined result
via the protocol uh handler mechanism
support you mentioned before
where the url when you hover you around
all custom url
on the native side you get like
that uh a back on that an objective c so
like the entire like threading
piece on it is very very quirky
okay well i guess that's why uh i use
cordova to just
take care of this
yeah they've just started producing them
there's a repository of plugins that
exist
they're kind of still very basic nothing
but there might be something
yeah there's definitely yeah it's still
a very young project i would say
right so so as i as as the versions of
quarterback were getting updated my
stuff just kept breaking and i spent a
lot of time you know just
bashing up portable really well i don't
know if you know
i would i would i would post a question
and then nobody would answer it then i
would answer my own question and then
that would
that change would make it into a quarter
of us so i don't know if that's just a
coincidence
so yeah so you can uh so quarter will
lets you
get values back from objective c
functions
in your javascript callbacks
and these are the different that value
types that you can get
and you know cordova handles the
conversion between javascript and the
native
data type
so there are also limitations on when
you go into background mode
javascript freezes so uh
if you got something going on that has
to finish
like even if you're going to background
mode on ios you get
you can request like an extra three
minutes to complete things
like you know if you're writing user
data or something like that
and so if you want to do something like
that the portable file api does not
provide this protection so you
you want to do a custom plugin if you
were doing something like that
so i think if you were doing something
like in the real world you'd probably
end up writing a lot of custom plugins
but it's fairly straightforward to do
that so it's i don't think that's like
such a big
annoyance and you can just keep them
minimal and do
as much as you can in javascript or
other clojure script
and certain kinds of apps also are
allowed
by apple to run in the background
indefinitely
but you've got to be a specific kind of
app and you got to declare that
for example something that plays audible
content that's got to be able to run
indefinitely
in the background so if you got anything
like that that should also be delegated
that kind of functionality
to a plug-in to the native side
all right so now i want to talk about
how clojurescript fit into the picture
for me just the basic
building blocks that i used uh yeah i'm
not going to talk so much about my app
that's not really about the app it's
just about the architecture of the app
and how one might go about
doing something like this so uh core
async is a huge help
with handling first of all the all these
apis the portable apis are callback apis
so with core async i this was this was
one of the things i wanted to learn and
i used this project to
sort of get familiar with core async so
it's really helpful in handling the
callback apis
and also when you're getting the touch
input from the user
it's very helpful for doing that
rather than uh again having callbacks
fire all over the place you just put
things on channels
and the other sort of big win in my view
is the or the home library that david
wrote for doing user interfaces in
javascript and of course you get the
repl
and i want to talk about this client
server setup that i got going on that
just kind of makes
uh development a little bit smoother
so when i'm developing i i've got my
native app running on the phone
that's on the left and i just package an
index html in there and all it does it
just redirects to a web server running
on my development machine
that serves up that whole uh website
right
and then anytime i want to update it i
just update
the files on my local on my development
machine and i just reload the
the browser widget from the repl or
another thing i do is i'll just
just you know somewhere in the browser
widget have a little place like a
refresh button that i can just
refresh so they're just you know if you
didn't do that you'd have to
every time you make a little change in
your javascript html you gotta repack
it you recompile and repackage the app
and xcode and
it's a little bit annoying to have to do
that all the time
i found that light table it was the most
stable in connecting
to the
browser window running on the phone and
if you have any
changes that you have to make to native
code obviously you still have to
recompile and rerun
so this is how i used core async
to handle api equals this is if you're
not familiar with core racing this is
just a very sort of brief
intro to how you would do that you so no
so on top is just the sort of the
regular setup you have your api call
you get a call back and it fires you
know when it fires
you don't have any control over when it
fires
and on the bottom is what you do is you
you know you have your same api call
and then what you do in the callback
that you pass in all that callback does
is just put
the value on the core async channel
and then you can do this sort of parking
read and you you can basically read from
the channel whenever you want to so
you're kind of back in control now
and you know you don't have the logic of
your program spread all over the
pullback so that makes
made it really neat and just made it a
lot easier to think about things
so this is just an a an example of how i
use the
core async
i don't know if this is really the best
way to do things so i'm actually curious
with
you know if i'm doing something funky
here but so so
for example i'm trying to get here on
the left side the function getfs is just
attempting to get to the file system
and we're using the cordova
api request file system right there to
ask for it
and over here we are we're going to put
that value on a channel
which we've declared here in the let and
the whole thing is in a gold block which
the the gold bug will immediately return
a channel and then
when this when the request file system
gets us back a value we put it back in
the channel
and we read it off that channel right on
the very bottom
so that the thing that calls getfs
will get a channel which will eventually
contain the file system
that was returned by request file system
and so the function of on the right now
we'll use
the function on the left get get fs
again it has to be inside a gold block
because we're now in kind of the async
world
and inside the led on the right there we
call
get a fs and we bind it to fs
but we first have to read off of it
because getifs
again gives us back a channel not the
actual value but the channel will
contain the value when it gets there
and so now this looks a little bit more
like sort of your synchronous code
just except you have to read off a
channel
rather than you know directly get the
value
and so you can kind of chain these
functions
more easily this way
okay the other thing that core async is
really useful for is
handling touch input this is a very
common pattern that
you know i've seen people use is just
again whenever there's any kind of a
touch event you just
uh you just put it on the channel
and then you can you can get a loop
going where you read
this channel and you just and you just
process
these input values i just want to show
you
it's just a big ass loop really
i'm not going to show you it's going to
take too long
i changed my mind
no because i got to figure out how to
adjust the font and all that
you have to go back to slide yeah
it's just frozen now
let's continue like this i don't know
what's going on
that right we're right next
okay thank you very much whoever helped
me out and i was just listening not
looking
uh right so i'm not going to show you
but uh
now for building the user interface you
you now you're so
if you were doing things this way you
would not be using the native sdk to
build the user interface
you might consider using react no
i i'm going to show you it's very basic
and simple
just how to do touch gesture detection
right because now you don't have
in the gesture detection you have to
write that in javascript or clojure
script
and but before i get to that i just want
to mention that you get very few
transitions with css5 transitions if you
use translate
3d rather than the 2d version
and it's faster as i discovered on the
internet
due to hardware acceleration
only on the iphone okay
okay so this is one of those points
where
you're not going to be able to use
things across
yeah so so there's a lot of things like
that that where things break down so
for the react piece is that actually
pulled directly from
facebook servers or is that like well no
you you you you
you pull and home but just in case
people were not familiar with react i
just wanted to mention that it's
all built
a underneath poll like you mentioned no
no no i
no no i store it local i wouldn't yeah i
don't know like
right so that only works on the iphone
apparently yeah i did this on the iphone
i did not
do this across because i have an iphone
so that's what's easier for me
and i just want to also mention that you
can present the native ui views
if you want to you can and if it's
convenient to do so for example
in my case i had to access the music
and there's already a sort of this this
thing mp media picker controller that
you know it presents a nice view of all
your music organized and then the user
just picks and you get it so i just used
it and you can do that
recorder yeah you do it's still through
cordova so
it's just it's just another plugin it's
just another javascript function called
to that view
that view pops up you select whatever
you disappears you back to your window
all right touch and gesture detection so
in javascript
you've got uh the three basic touch
events that you get
touch start touch move touch end and you
build
your gesture detection on top of that
i'm not going to show you but
if i can do it you can do it
all right so the other sort of really
helpful piece
for building the user interface's own
and react if you're not familiar
i will briefly mention what these things
are so
react.js is a is a javascript library
for building user interfaces
built by facebook some folks at facebook
it's really cool
it just uh it just periodically
re-renders the dom
at like a certain interval and uh
it it just bashes the right the rights
to the dom right because they're
expensive
and so it keeps this virtual dom
and then anytime it wants to make
an update it just calculates a minimal
update path and it tries to
optimize things that way and pete hunt
who's a fellow that's
that i found on the internet who talks a
lot about react.js so i assume he's
really involved with the project
he says they can get 60 frames per
second
on non-jet phone and see i
see this is proof that i knew about ios
8 having jet
and i kind of i'm going to let david
nolan speak about what ohm is
so i type it here from github all allows
users to represent their ui
simply as eden so you basically have an
atom with your
app state and that represents your whole
ui
and then because closure script data is
immutable one can always rapidly
re-render the ui from the root thus om
uis are out of the
box snapshottable and undoable and for
me that was the really
cool part because it simplifies testing
and debugging
and you get undo kind of for free so
that's really neat
i hear it's really hard to do actually
and i never tried but i believe the
people who say that
if you want to find out more you should
check out david nolan's look i think
this is really cool if you're doing user
interfaces you might want to be aware of
it if you're not already
yeah and only it's really declarative
so that's what makes it really neat
i was i did want to show you an own
component let me see if i can
manage to adjust the funds after all
i'm just always afraid to go into the
preferences
bam okay so the the loop that i wanted
to show you earlier
oh damn
right so you have this ui chan
and all the things
all the inputs basically all the things
that the user does
they go on that channel and then you
have this golu that just got this
constantly reading from the channel and
it's just
processing the various things that come
in and it's all here in this one loop
and you know you want to
figure things out
it's all in one place it's nice and neat
and uh let me see if i can find a
i think
if i can find them
i seem to have misplaced my own
component
here it is so this is just a quick
example of an home component
menu item that's a known component
and the way the way you
do it is you basically implement a bunch
of protocols
and that gets you a component so
i init state that's your initial state
in this case we just
have a channel here
that's just that you're going to have
access to the channel throughout the
life cycle if i understand correctly of
this component
right i will mount this another protocol
that you implement
and what we're doing here is we're
getting that channel
that we declared here
and then we pass that channel to a
function that i wrote
that's the one that detects gestures it
takes a channel
and then when it happens to the text a
gesture
it just puts it
on the ui chain
right so that's how you would wire up
the
touch event detection of touch events on
your component
so it's all right here in one spot and
then this is kind of the i render state
or i render depending if they're state
or not
that is the meat and potatoes of the
library that is how you render actual
components
and so the way you do it you don't have
like a templating uh
language you just use closure script
which is
i think better unless you need to kind
of i don't know i i've been doing it
that way and it feels better to me
personally i don't know if you'd like it
but and and so here's how you wire that
up
and it's all right here and you can and
you can have components inside of
components and then you can
and then you do something like what i'm
doing here
to build components consisting of
multiple other components
etc etc
all right so these are as i see in just
the basic trade-offs
uh you know the obvious pros that you
get closure semantics
and that's really cool uh you know the
ui is in javascript html css that is
either a pro icon depending on your
point of view i don't know i'm not sure
i don't build a lot of user interfaces
it's probably powerful but probably has
limitations
and i think a big win could be if you
have something on the server side that's
talking to your app to have closure and
even
you know doing that i think that can
give you a lot of leverage
uh the cons might be that it's not as
performant
so maybe if you need to squeeze every
last ounce
out of your wrap you might not want to
go this route maybe your ui cannot be as
rich i don't know
and it's a little bit more complex
that's all i got thanks guys
yes please questions um what was your
sense of
the performance drop off i did not
if i had a very basic app i did so i'll
tell you the kind of things i did
i i got a i got us i picked a song from
the
iphone library i uh created a waveform
that would run as the song would play
there was no performance drop off the
everything was for simple things like
that there's you don't feel any
difference it feels just like
yeah i tried i really tried yeah
i thought like i tested yes please so
suppose
you want to
yes you could do that that would
actually work
you could do that yeah because because
if you can get the one ui element you
can get
at any of them my first answer is yeah
you
you could wire it up that way it would
be a little tricky
but i think you could do it there's
actually a
javascript finder a direct binding
between just javascript knowing
and objective c so what you can do is
you come from there you can from
javascript
directly call objective c chords and
from object to c vector javascript
if you take an object let's say a
javascript dot like an array
and you put it on bridge that will
convert it into an um
into a js value and object to c and then
you can use it they're not going to
write
so that would actually allow you to run
closely with all that bridge but but
the interface with the api you have to
build each
one yeah so who wants to do another
objective
well i didn't do anything very complex
and i didn't find it more difficult than
say doing it purely in export but maybe
if things get more complex
i could see that being more becoming
more and more of an issue
okay
yeah so you sort of reconvinced me again
a decision i made a couple years ago to
just
go with html5 and not worry about
you know complying with ios and android
and so
learning through right through different
things i used to do a lot of
in adobe flex air development which was
sort of a precursor to i told you an
adobe platform
um their hmo5 is very rapidly moving
technology
and it has built into it like web
sockets and stuff where you can have
very fast bi-directional
transfer data have you thought about
integrating that in here i have not
thought about that at all
but i will think about it in the future
with doing this is that like the actual
webview itself
doesn't support a lot of that so don't
assume that the actual like webview is
like
you know mobile safari or chrome or
anything like that
and on android the actual webview that
you get up until about four four three
four two four three is actually like
four years old uh they completely
attribute support for
and then for two uh
you actually get a chromium window and
they actually do it by a few provider
api so they've gone to the whole thing
so that's what i'm saying before about
the testing is just a nightmare because
on android
you never know what kind of perhaps
you're getting you can get chromium you
can get chrome you can get the old
webview
or you can get firefighters if you want
so
and all of them implement those html5
standards differently
so you got all that
um
that they take into account the actual
webview itself which is different from
the actual browser
and then also you have to take into
account the version right so it's like
you have to look at the android content
it's looking at what's the major rev
what's the minor wrap because like
google's quality control in general on
amber is atrocious
for cordova's piece it actually grows
because they used to actually check java
objects directly into the
javascript vm context you can't do that
you can't do it on ios but you know
objective c does allow you to do it
you could do it on the java side of
things for android
and used to be able to say for your
injected java object in the javascript
just called method on it
until like you know google forgot to
that they broke it and two threesome
entire major rev version stops
at every single corner of the app or i
think they use the same technology
so those would be the risks
right right when it actually have to go
through on the
native side into the javascript context
it's actually going through the
message it captures it traps it on the
javascript side and says
is the message that you're passing back
like one of our control apis if
somebody's a good quality of guy
otherwise say hi i'm here you know
dismissed
kind of thing okay so
okay have you looked at all i know
i don't know i believe they at least
plan to support it they might already
support
it i don't know though is it just
regular like html
but the you know 0.00
it's an emerging technology yeah the uh
the guy that did
uh
yeah push notifications i don't think
you're actually using them but
i'm not cordova supports it or no
you mean the objective c notifications
that you get
uh yeah yeah so you mentioned i mean
or or whatever yeah yeah so like if
you're if graph's not actually running
but it's registered itself as a uh
yes receiving could you know could
receive right when something comes in so
you could do that yeah
so you could do that in your plugin you
can you can receive them
and you can if you want put things on
the channel as you receive them
to to pass it back to uh
javascript quota script land but
remember it freezes
when you go into background mode right
so that's the
but yeah you can access that yes how did
you successfully
submit an app no no i did not
this project succeed
that's another risk yeah yes do you find
it like a little bit
um like onerous or like
tired tiresome like the setup channels
for like
every parent i'm going to talk to every
child component
i know i know that like if you have a
question
you're talking about when i did the the
chaining of the functions that
were like having a sure like or just
setting up
i noticed like when i worked with home i
just said a lot of channels
to where parents and components can sort
of get information from
children i see you probably have a bit
more experience with them see i when i
started this project
i saw on pop-up and i spoke with david
and he said don't you know it just just
you just you know it just
so he said don't do it and don't touch
it
and so i didn't do it with all and then
i started converting it with own that's
just one of the first
and so i don't know what it's like to
have a lot of home components so i
you're probably i'm better qualified to
speak on this so
i can't answer that yeah
so it's not coming from the parent then
where would you say
i guess as opposed to having just a new
channel getting set up with each
level sub component just have one
callback go up one level
another maybe way you can do it is
digital problem like this but like pass
the entire data uh
all of the like the app state down is
like an option
like this i can see a patch like there's
a extra option
then instructor david that way sorry
i mean having a separate ui tree is
how every other moving system works i
think you make
you forget the work you use but it's
essentially a transaction right you
start it you make all your changes at
the end of the transaction
it's basically doing diffs all the way
down because it's counting on the
immutability
as opposed to the regular reactions it
actually has to walk the whole tree
because it can't stay
right yeah because it can't say exactly
where
the change happened you're talking about
the event
is
it's not implemented so is it possible
for us sub cursor to actually get
evolved
that you are like a smaller component
you can access people
i'm curious about the gestures is there
like two finger gestures
and do you have to you have to implement
all the gestures yourself that you want
i'm i'm pretty sure pretty soon there's
going to be just a javascript library
that does all this
i i looked casually and there wasn't
anything that i saw
but it's it's fairly straightforward
like i said earlier
i managed to do it like pretty quickly
so
anyone else thank you guys